Ce matin, nous allons reprendre là où nous étions arrêtés dernièrement sur ce...
Alors, je pense que ça va être un rappel pour ceux qui avaient pu suivre la prédication.
Comme vous avez pu le constater à la lecture de ce texte,
les menaces qui sont partagées dans ce texte,
ce sont des menaces qui avaient été déjà partagées dans les chapitres suivants, si vous vous souvenez.
Il suffit même juste de lire les versets, je pense, les versets 5 au verset 7.
Vous allez voir que ce sont ces aspects qui sont répétés dans les versets que nous venons de lire.
Mais cette fois-ci, lorsque nous sommes en train de lire ce texte,
nous voyons que l'emphase est mise sur le prophète.
C'est-à-dire que là, Dieu n'est pas juste en train de dire à Ézéchiel,
Dieu n'est pas juste en train d'utiliser Ézéchiel pour parler au peuple.
Dieu est en train de parler à Ézéchiel aussi.
Dieu parle à Ézéchiel et il lui demande de pouvoir, par ce qu'il doit faire,
donc il lui dit, verset 11,
Ainsi parle le Seigneur l'Éternel, frappe de la main, frappe du pied et dit, hélas,
Dieu demandait à Ézéchiel de pouvoir éprouver cette tristesse à cause du jugement à venir.
Et il ne devait pas juste éprouver cette tristesse, il devait aussi pouvoir démontrer cette tristesse,
afin que ceux à qui il avait prophétisé, ceux-là puissent prendre davantage conscience.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est la vérité centrale qui ressort aussi là-dessus.
Et c'est une vérité aussi, vous voyez, là, je pense que quand nous avons lu le texte,
il est difficile pour nous de pouvoir voir un aspect de joie ou un aspect d'encouragement là-dedans.
Mais nous voyons quand même comment Dieu est en train d'enseigner à Ézéchiel
à ne pas juste en train de proclamer la vérité, mais de proclamer la vérité avec compassion.
Et il doit proclamer la vérité avec compassion, mais il doit aussi pouvoir démontrer,
proclamer la vérité avec compassion et pouvoir démontrer sa compassion.
Donc avant, ça c'est pour la vérité centrale,
et donc avant de revenir sur les points principaux de la prédication,
je redonne rapidement le contexte.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est important pour nous de ne pas juste nous situer
sur l'événement d'Ézéchiel.
C'est de comprendre, d'avoir une plus grande image.
En anglais, on va dire big picture, mais je ne sais pas.
Une plus grande image, on va rester sur ça.
Une plus grande image de cette compréhension, c'est l'œuvre de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire, il y a la chute dans le jardin,
mais Dieu promet dans le jardin d'Éden, Adam et Ève chutent,
mais Dieu leur fait la promesse qu'il va restaurer toutes choses un jour.
Et quand Dieu fait cette promesse, plus tard, il va s'acquérir un peuple,
il va lever Abraham, il va lui promettre à un moment qu'Abraham sera,
il aura une postérité, et d'Abraham va naître un peuple.
Ce peuple va être esclave en Égypte, Dieu les délivre,
c'est très important à préciser, ils étaient esclaves en Égypte,
et Dieu les délivre.
Et quand Dieu les délivre, il leur dit,
vous êtes maintenant mon peuple, et je suis votre Dieu.
C'était quelque chose d'important, parce que le peuple aussi s'engage,
du moment où c'est ce Dieu qui les délivre,
le peuple s'engage à ce que Dieu soit leur Dieu.
Et donc Dieu établit une alliance avec eux,
il leur promet une terre, la terre promise,
il les emmène sur cette terre de Canaan,
il les établit sur cette terre de Canaan,
et il leur dit à un moment, vous ne la quitterez jamais
si vous respectez la loi, l'alliance que j'établis avec vous.
Mais après plusieurs siècles, on constate que,
malgré la patience de Dieu,
Israël n'a pas obéi à la loi établie avec Dieu.
Israël n'a pas obéi à l'alliance,
et à cause de cela, tout ce que Dieu avait annoncé,
en cas de désobéissance à l'alliance,
c'était tout ce qui est en train d'être dit par Jérémie,
qui va être dit par Jérémie, par Ésaïe, par Ézéchiel et d'autres prophètes.
Et donc là, nous avons lu,
et donc là, quand Dieu fait ça,
une des premières choses qui se manifestent par rapport à ce jugement,
c'est que ce royaume qui devait être uni,
va être éclaté en deux.
Il y a le royaume du nord, dix tribus d'Israël,
et le royaume du sud,
qui va être ce qu'on appelle le royaume du juda avec deux autres tribus.
Le royaume du nord va être détruit,
à cause aussi justement du fait qu'il n'avait pas respecté l'alliance établie avec Dieu.
Le royaume du nord est détruit,
et une partie de la population va être déportée,
mais une autre partie va aussi se réfugier dans le royaume du sud.
Et par la suite,
Dieu parle aussi,
à cause de ce péché toujours,
du péché et du fait de ne pas avoir honoré Dieu comme étant leur Dieu,
le jugement arrive sur le royaume du sud.
Et quand le jugement arrive,
il arrive par des nations étrangères,
là c'est Babylone,
et donc Babylone va attaquer une première fois,
et ils vont déporter une partie de la population parmi la noblesse.
Et c'est comme ça que Daniel,
Ézéchiel vont être déportés à Babylone.
Et c'est à Babylone que Dieu se révèle à Ézéchiel,
et lui rappelle un moment pourquoi toutes ces choses leur arrivent.
Toutes ces choses leur arrivent parce qu'ils n'ont pas obéi à l'alliance,
qu'ils avaient établie avec Dieu.
Et à cause de ça,
tous ces jugements vont arriver.
Mais Dieu promet aussi,
Dieu promet aussi que
il était normal qu'ils ne puissent pas respecter cette alliance,
parce qu'ils en étaient incapables.
Et c'était aussi pour les amener à pointer vers le Christ.
Mais pour ce matin,
donc là je vous rappelle un peu ce contexte-là,
et donc Dieu parle à Ézéchiel
pour qu'Ézéchiel rappelle au peuple,
parce qu'ils étaient confus.
Pour certains,
ils pensaient que c'était quelque chose de naturel qui est arrivé,
d'autres rejetaient le fait que ce soit un jugement de Dieu,
et d'autres même pensaient que Dieu était encore avec eux.
Et donc que ce jugement est arrivé,
et que Dieu allait juger Babylone,
ils allaient pouvoir rentrer.
Mais Dieu leur dit à un moment,
vous ne rentrerez pas,
parce que c'est un jugement,
c'est moi qui ai fait ce jugement,
et ce jugement ira jusqu'à son terme.
Donc Ézéchiel est en train de les exerter dans ce sens.
Et lorsque Dieu l'amène maintenant
à une série de prophéties,
donc c'est là une série de messages,
nous avions commencé dans le chapitre 6,
donc les premiers versets,
versets 1 à 10,
il est en train déjà de parler maintenant
pour l'ensemble du pays,
d'annoncer ces jugements.
Et donc, là nous revenons maintenant
sur notre texte,
du verset 11 au verset 14,
c'était le rappel,
pour vous aider un peu à comprendre un peu le contexte.
Nous pouvons maintenant revenir sur les points
qui sont liés à notre vérité centrale du jour.
La vérité c'était de voir comment Dieu,
ancien à Ézéchiel,
avoir de la compassion pour le peuple.
C'est-à-dire que même lorsque Dieu est en train d'annoncer
ses jugements par la famine,
par la peste,
par l'exil,
Dieu est en train de leur dire un moment,
je le fais parce que je vous aime.
C'était ça qui était difficile à un moment à comprendre.
Et voilà pourquoi à un moment,
nous avions mis l'emphase sur le fait que
la colère de Dieu ne devait pas être comprise
selon notre façon de voir les choses,
mais nous devions la comprendre selon le principe biblique.
De même, lorsqu'on va parler de l'amour de Dieu,
il est difficile de voir que quand Dieu manifeste un jugement
par l'épée, par la famine, par la peste, par l'exil,
pour nous c'est difficile de voir de l'amour.
Si nous voyons des êtres humains faire cela à notre peuple,
nous n'allons pas dire que ces gens aiment.
Mais Dieu est en train,
c'était ça qui était aussi assez bizarre,
c'est que Dieu aimait Israël.
Et ces jugements arrivaient
parce que Dieu était en train de purifier Israël.
Donc, le premier point,
c'est que Dieu veut amener Israël
à éprouver de la compassion
envers ceux à qui il est en train d'annoncer
les jugements à venir.
Donc c'est le verset 11.
Ainsi parle le Seigneur l'Éternel,
frappe de la main, frappe du pied,
et dit hélas sur toutes les méchantes abominations
de la maison d'Israël,
qui tombera par l'épée, par la famine,
et par la peste.
Concentrons-nous déjà sur...
Ainsi parle le Seigneur l'Éternel,
frappe de la main, frappe du pied.
Par ces gestes,
Ézéchiel devait exprimer
la compréhension profonde
qu'il avait à la fois des iniquités
et des jugements
qui étaient en train de tomber sur Israël.
Ce que Dieu lui demandait
au travers de l'exécution de ces gestes,
vous voyez,
si vous pouvez essayer de vous mettre
à la place d'Ézéchiel,
quand Dieu va lui dire,
allez, maintenant, frappe,
frappe de la main,
ça fait assez bizarre,
mais ça attire l'attention.
Et quand il est en train de faire ça,
il était aussi en train de montrer
le sérieux,
le sérieux dans lequel
il était en train d'annoncer ces choses.
Il était en train d'annoncer
qu'il y croyait fermement.
Gérardement,
si à un moment,
on ne croit pas à quelque chose,
on va juste le dire,
on va être immobile,
on ne va pas faire de gestes,
on va juste le dire du bout des lèvres.
Mais là, il était même en train
de l'exprimer par l'engagement de son corps.
C'était pour que ce soit quelque chose
qui soit en train de marquer ses auditeurs.
Peut-être qu'il y en a qui allaient rire de ça.
Peut-être même que là,
vous avez rigolé quand vous avez vu faire ça.
Peut-être certains allaient en rire,
d'autres allaient le mépriser
par rapport à cela.
Mais Dieu lui demandait de le faire
afin que ses auditeurs puissent prendre conscience.
Mais si Ézéchiel comprenait l'importance du message
qui en découlait pour le salut de leurs âmes,
alors Ézéchiel allait obéir.
Même au prix de sa réputation,
Ézéchiel allait obéir,
même si ça pouvait,
et vous voyez déjà là,
je pense même que ça,
c'est encore un peu plus simple
que ce que nous avons déjà parcouru
quand Dieu lui demande de se coucher d'un côté,
de pouvoir dessiner,
de pouvoir,
toutes ces choses,
de pouvoir même manger
certaines choses,
des excréments d'animaux.
Donc toutes ces choses-là,
c'était déjà assez difficile.
Mais Ézéchiel est en train de prendre conscience
que de tout cela dépend le salut
des âmes à qui il est en train de parler.
Nous devons prendre conscience.
C'est un rappel,
et c'est bien aussi que nous soyons dans cette conscience.
En ce matin, en ce week-end,
nous sommes en train de célébrer
le 508e anniversaire de la réforme protestante,
c'est de prendre conscience de la réalité.
Et voilà pourquoi j'ai redonné ce contexte
pour rappeler même un moment
que quand nous parlons même de la réforme,
la réforme n'est qu'un tout petit point
dans l'histoire entre Dieu et son peuple.
Dans l'histoire où, à un moment,
le peuple de Dieu va être amené
à se détourner de lui,
va oublier l'alliance,
et Dieu va ramener l'alliance.
Ce qui s'est passé dans la réforme,
nous pouvons le lire plusieurs fois dans la Bible.
D'ailleurs, un des épisodes les plus marquants dans la Bible,
ça va être l'épisode avec le roi Josias.
Comment Josias va rétablir le culte de l'éternel.
Et ça, c'est une réforme.
Si vous voulez lire l'exemple même d'une réforme
d'une façon biblique,
vous pouvez relire le travail que Josias va faire.
C'est vraiment le principe d'une réforme.
Et c'est cette conscience pour nous.
Est-ce que nous avons conscience
que le monde entier est sous la puissance du malin ?
que les personnes que nous croisons dans la rue chaque jour,
est-ce que ces personnes ont déjà entendu l'évangile ?
Est-ce que nous avons cette conscience
de la finalité pour leurs âmes ?
Et lorsque Dieu était en train d'amener
Ézéchiel à pouvoir exprimer ça,
c'est qu'Ézéchiel devait prendre,
par la manifestation,
déjà toutes ces choses que Dieu lui avait demandé de faire,
il devait être en train de témoigner le sérieux,
de prendre conscience
que ce n'étaient pas juste des paroles
qu'il était en train de balancer en l'air.
Il devait être en train de prendre conscience
qu'il était nécessaire
que le peuple comprenne que Dieu les appelait à la repentance.
Il y avait un but derrière tout cela.
Nous aussi, nous devons comprendre un moment
par les gestes auxquels Dieu nous appelle,
par la parole à laquelle Dieu nous appelle,
nous devons comprendre aussi
que témoigner de l'évangile
demande aussi du sérieux dans le message que nous annonçons.
Et si nous sommes conscients un moment
du message que nous annonçons,
nous allons prendre conscience
de ce que nos gestes traduisent vis-à-vis des autres,
de ce que nos paroles traduisent vis-à-vis des autres,
parce que nous avons quoi ?
Conscience du salut
de ceux qui sont devant nous.
Dieu ne nous a pas donné
un esprit de timidité
ou un esprit de peur,
mais il nous a donné un esprit de force.
Et je vais revenir là-dessus
pendant la prédiction.
Dieu nous a donné un esprit de force,
un esprit d'amour et de sagesse
pour annoncer l'évangile.
Et c'est intéressant,
pendant que nous sommes en train de fêter
l'anniversaire de la réforme,
c'est aussi de nous encourager,
de l'encouragement à avoir des frères comme Ézéchiel,
des frères comme Luther, Calvin,
Heuss et plein d'autres,
et bien d'autres,
qui n'ont pas eu honte du témoignage
à rendre à Dieu.
Là, nous parlons d'une situation
où ces hommes,
en prenant conscience de la vérité,
ont choisi de sacrifier leur réputation,
ont choisi de sacrifier leur vie
parce qu'ils savaient
qu'ils proclamaient la vérité.
Ils ont choisi de sacrifier leur vie
parce qu'ils étaient conscients
à un moment que
ce qu'ils avaient entendu
et vu du Seigneur était vrai.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
nous sommes dans cette situation,
est-ce que tu es conscient
que ce que tu as vu
et entendu du Seigneur est vrai ?
C'est aussi un des éléments
qui déterminent la conversion.
Hier, je rappelais
à des bien aimants discutants,
je leur disais
Dieu ne nous appelle pas
à être des défenseurs de Dieu.
Dieu nous appelle
à être des témoins.
Le témoin rapporte
ce qu'il a vu.
Et souvent,
nous allons souvent rentrer
dans beaucoup de choses
où on veut être défenseur de Dieu
alors que ce n'est pas
ce que Dieu nous demande.
Dieu se suffit à lui-même.
Dieu est assez puissant
pour se défendre lui-même.
Dieu nous demande
d'être témoins.
Des témoins,
des ambassadeurs de Christ
pour appeler les personnes
à pouvoir se réconcilier avec Dieu.
Nous devons être témoins
et en tant que témoins,
nous devons dire
ce que nous avons vu
et entendu de Dieu,
que ce soit dans nos vies
ou dans la vie
d'autres personnes.
Nous devons prendre conscience,
tout comme ces hommes
ont sacrifié leur réputation,
ont sacrifié leur vie.
Et là, nous parlons,
Tindel, je pense qu'hier
quand notre frère Christian
a fait le rappel,
il a beaucoup partagé là-dessus,
mais remarquant,
des hommes qui sont allés
jusqu'au bûcher
et qui ont accepté
d'être brûlés
parce qu'ils croyaient
en la vérité de l'Évangile.
Tout comme eux,
nous devons souffrir
pour la cause de l'Évangile,
même si cela peut occasionner
des railleries,
des souffrances.
Pourquoi nous souffrons
pour la cause de l'Évangile?
C'est parce que nous avons
pris conscience du Dieu
qui nous a sauvés.
Nous avons pris conscience
du Dieu qui nous a adressés
une sainte vocation.
Nous avons pris conscience
du Dieu qui nous a sauvés
non à cause de nos œuvres
ou de notre mérite,
mais qui nous a sauvés
pour son propre dessein,
qui nous a sauvés
par la grâce
qui nous a été donnée
en Jésus-Christ.
Et cette grâce
que nous avons reçue
gratuitement,
c'est une grâce aussi
que nous nous devons
de partager gratuitement.
En faisant cela,
nous serons,
même si nous pouvons
être dans la souffrance,
dans la raillerie,
nous serons
la bonne odeur de Christ
parmi ceux
qui sont sauvés,
qui périssent.
Et je vais lire,
je ne l'avais pas prévu,
mais c'est bien
de toujours pouvoir
prendre conscience.
Voilà ce que Paul dit
à un moment.
et souvent,
nous devons accepter
le fait que ça peut
nous arriver.
Et j'exhortais
vendredi aussi
en disant un moment
quand nous
prenons l'expression
de dire
par chance,
donc je corrigeais
une prière
qui avait été faite
vendredi
parce qu'on disait
nous avons la chance
d'être dans un pays
où nous ne sommes pas
persécutés.
Ce n'est pas une chance.
nous avons la grâce
de Dieu,
mais dans cette grâce,
Dieu peut permettre
aussi qu'il y ait
la persécution.
Mais dans tous les cas,
nous ne verrons pas ça
comme une malchance.
Si nous sommes persécutés,
ce n'est pas de la malchance.
c'est une joie
de souffrir pour Christ.
Voilà ce que Paul dit
à un moment
dans 2 Corinthiens 6.
2 Corinthiens 6
à partir du verset,
je vais même lire
à partir du verset 1,
et c'est bien
pour vraiment illustrer ça.
Verset 1
au verset 10.
Il dit
« Puisque nous travaillons
avec Dieu,
nous vous exhortons
à ne pas recevoir
la grâce de Dieu en vain.
Car il dit
« Au temps favorable,
je t'ai exaucé,
au jour du salut,
je t'ai secouru.
Voici maintenant
le temps favorable,
voici maintenant
le jour du salut.
Nous ne donnons
aucun sujet de scandale
en quoi que ce soit
afin que le ministère
ne soit pas
un objet de blâme. »
Voilà ce que Dieu
à un moment
quand par nos gestes,
par nos paroles,
nous devons témoigner
du sérieux de l'Évangile.
Voilà ce que Paul
est en train de dire
dans ce sens.
Mais nous nous rendons
à tous égards
recommandables
comme serviteurs de Dieu
par beaucoup de patience
dans les tribulations,
dans les calamités,
dans les détresses,
sous les coups,
dans les prisons,
dans les troubles,
dans les travaux,
dans les veilles,
dans les jeûnes,
par la pureté,
par la connaissance,
par la longanimité,
par la bonté,
par un esprit saint,
par une charité sincère,
par la parole de vérité,
par la puissance de Dieu,
par les armes offensives
et défensives de la justice,
au milieu de la gloire
et de l'ignominie,
au milieu de la mauvaise
et de la bonne réputation,
étant regardés
comme imposteurs,
quoique véridiques,
comme inconnus,
quoique bien connus,
comme mourants
et voici nous vivants,
comme châtiés,
quoique non mis à mort,
comme attristés
et nous sommes toujours joyeux,
comme pauvres
et nous en enrichissons plusieurs,
comme n'ayant rien
et nous possédons
toutes choses.
Pourquoi Paul est en train de dire
qu'ils acceptent
de souffrir toutes ces choses ?
C'est parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
se taire
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont vu
et entendu
et en réalisant
qui Dieu est pour eux.
et Ézéchiel,
en prenant conscience
de cela,
de qui Dieu était
pour Ézéchiel,
pour son peuple,
Ézéchiel obéit.
Et donc,
Dieu lui dit un moment,
donc il y avait,
ainsi parle le Seigneur,
frappe de la main,
frappe du pied
et ensuite il dit,
et dit,
hélas,
sous toutes les méchantes
abominations
de la maison d'Israël
qui tombera par l'épée,
par la famine
et par la peste.
Le deuxième aspect
de ce verset,
donc Dieu ne demande pas juste
de manifester par les gestes,
Ézéchiel devait aussi parler
dans son expression,
il devait parler
en déplorant,
donc c'est ce terme,
hélas,
le mot hélas,
les méchantes abominations
d'Israël
et les différentes manifestations
du jugement.
Ce premier point,
Ézéchiel devait ressentir
une peine
pour les péchés quotidiens
et répétés d'Israël.
C'est-à-dire,
il ne fallait pas juste
qu'Ézéchiel soit en train
d'annoncer ce message,
mais il fallait
qu'Ézéchiel aussi
soit conscient,
soit conscient
de ce que le péché
était en train
de produire.
La paix de Dieu
peut habiter notre cœur
de croyant,
mais nous devons
et nous allons
toujours ressentir,
quand la parole de Dieu
est en train
d'être vivante
dans nos cœurs,
nous allons toujours
ressentir de la peine
quand nous voyons
l'immoralité,
nous voyons la dépravation,
nous voyons le péché
autour de nous.
Le psalmiste rappelle
qu'une colère ardente
le saisit à la vue
des méchants
qui abandonnent
la loi de Dieu.
Et c'est dans ce sens,
quand on dit à un moment,
vous avez reçu un esprit
de force,
d'amour et de sagesse,
c'est cet aspect de force
qui témoigne
de l'esprit de Dieu
qui habite en nous.
Nous sommes révoltés
par le péché.
Nous ne pouvons pas
juste être
en train de trouver
des choses normales
ou de nous taire
parce que nous trouvons
les choses normales.
Nous parlons
parce que nous connaissons
Dieu,
mais nous parlons aussi
parce que nous connaissons
ce que le péché est.
Et qu'est-ce que
le péché était là
dans ce cas
pour Ézéchiel ?
Épée,
famine,
peste.
Ézéchiel est en train
de se dire,
quand Ézéchiel
est en train
de dire cela,
les frères qui étaient restés,
Ézéchiel lui-même
était en train de vivre
les conséquences
de ce péché.
Vous voyez ?
Ézéchiel était déporté
à Babylone.
Daniel était déporté
Jérémie était en train
de vivre ça.
Jérémie a vécu
les dernières heures
du siège.
Donc à un moment,
ils ont été affamés.
Jérémie a été affamé
parce qu'il proclamait
la vérité.
On a même encore
plus affamé
que les autres.
Mais,
notre conscience,
c'est de toujours
être affecté
par nos propres péchés
et souffrances,
mais aussi par les péchés
et les souffrances
des autres.
Il ne s'agit pas juste
d'être attristé,
mais il nous faut aussi
éprouver de la compassion
face à la perdition.
Il nous faut éprouver
de la compassion
en voyant
les conséquences
des péchés
dans la vie des personnes.
À notre niveau,
ce que Dieu est en train
de demander à Ézéchiel
de faire,
c'est qu'en manifestant cela,
en parlant,
en déplorant
les abominations
de la maison d'Israël,
Ézéchiel était en train
de prendre conscience,
d'éprouver,
Dieu était en train
de façonner le cœur
d'Ézéchiel
pour qu'il éprouve
de la compassion.
Nous ne pouvons pas
annoncer l'Évangile,
nous ne pouvons pas
avoir vu et entendu
de Dieu
et annoncer ce message
sans compassion.
Le manque de compassion
nous amène nous-mêmes
à oublier
que nous avons été sauvés
par la grâce de Dieu.
Mais lorsque je suis déjà conscient
que par mes propres péchés,
je ne méritais même pas
la grâce de Dieu,
mais que j'ai été sauvé
et que cette grâce
s'est exercée dans ma vie,
alors je prends conscience aussi
que je me dois
d'annoncer ce message
pour que la grâce de Dieu
se manifeste
dans la vie de ceux
dont je vois
les conséquences du péché
en train d'être manifestées.
Un passage très important,
Matthieu 9, 36,
Le Seigneur Jésus
fut ému de compassion
car ceux qui étaient devant lui
étaient languissants,
abattus et sans repère.
Ça c'est...
Donc, dans Matthieu 9, 36,
vous avez le passage,
vous pouvez retrouver la référence.
Mais nous voyons
comment le Seigneur
était affecté en voyant.
À un moment,
qu'est-ce qui va
l'amener aussi à parler ?
C'est que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
est conscient de la mission
que Dieu lui donne.
Il doit annoncer
la parole du Père.
Mais il prend aussi conscience
de ce que ses auditeurs
sont devant lui.
Ils sont languissants,
ils sont touchés
par les effets du péché,
ils sont abattus,
ils sont sans repère.
Et on peut même résumer
ce que nous avons lu
des versets 11
au verset 14
d'Ézéchiel.
Nous pouvons le lire
lorsque nous lisons,
nous voyons dans Luc 19,
41 à 44,
c'est exactement
cette même chose
que Dieu demande
à Ézéchiel.
Comme il approchait
de la ville,
Jésus, en la voyant,
pleura sur elle
et dit,
si toi aussi au moins
en ce jour
qui t'es donné,
tu connaissais les choses
qui appartiennent
à ta paix,
mais maintenant
elles sont cachées
à tes yeux.
C'est ce hélas,
c'est-à-dire
qu'il est en train
d'être attristé
par rapport
au péché d'Israël
qui empêche Israël
de pouvoir voir le Messie.
Il viendra sur toi
les jours
où tes ennemis
t'environneront
de tranchées,
t'enfermeront
et te serviront
de toutes parts.
Ils te détruiront,
toi et tes enfants
au milieu de toi
et ils ne laisseront pas
en toi pierre sur pierre
parce que tu n'as pas
connu le temps
où tu as été visité.
Ce passage
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
de cette compassion
qu'il est en train
d'éprouver,
il est conscient
du message
mais il est aussi
conscient
de la perdition
de ce qu'il est
en train d'annoncer
et à cause de ça,
il n'y a pas juste
une indignation,
une indignation naturelle
mais il y a une intercession,
c'est-à-dire
il est en train
de prier
pour ces personnes,
il est en train
d'avoir de la compassion,
de prier,
il est en train
de les appeler
à la repentance,
il est en train
de leur rappeler
le jugement
qui est en train
de venir.
Vous voyez le parallèle
avec Ézéchiel 11,
14 est le même.
Et ce que le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ,
ce que Dieu
demande à Ézéchiel,
ce que nous voyons
au travers
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
c'est ce qui aussi
nous est demandé
aussi.
Nous aussi,
nous devons prendre
conscience.
Est-ce que
je suis
conscient
que la vérité,
je dois annoncer
cette vérité
à cause
de ce que Dieu
est pour moi ?
Ça, c'était
le premier point
que nous avions vu
mais là,
cette deuxième partie
du verset,
est-ce que je suis
conscient à un moment
que je dois annoncer
cette vérité
parce que
le péché
est en train
de détruire
les gens ?
Est-ce que
je ne suis pas,
il ne suffit pas juste,
vous voyez,
il ne suffit pas juste
de parler
mais il faut aussi
pouvoir éprouver
de la compassion
et la compassion
ne peut pas venir
si nous sommes
juste en train
de parler aux personnes,
de juste parler aux personnes.
La compassion vient
quand nous prions
pour ces personnes.
Est-ce que nous prions
est-ce que tu pries
pour les personnes
à qui tu es en train
d'annoncer l'évangile ?
Est-ce que tu pries
pour même les ennemis
qui sont en train
de se manifester
contre l'évangile ?
Nous voyons
l'exemple
d'Ézéchiel,
nous voyons l'exemple
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
nous voyons
comment ils sont
en train de prier
pour
ces auditeurs
qui étaient
perdus,
qui étaient abattus,
qui étaient sans repère
et parce qu'ils sont
en train de prier,
ils arrivent
à avoir de la compassion,
à sentir l'amour
que Dieu
a pour ses perdus.
Et parce qu'ils
arrivent
à avoir la compassion,
ils font cet appel
à la repentance.
Aujourd'hui,
pour beaucoup de personnes,
elles vont considérer
un moment
qu'on ne doit même pas
prêcher sur le péché.
Si nous devons
annoncer l'évangile
aux gens,
nous devons juste
leur dire
que Dieu est amour.
mais on ne doit pas
leur parler
sur le péché
et ses conséquences
dans leur vie.
Mais vous voyez,
l'appel à la repentance
fait partie
de l'amour
que nous portons
envers ceux
à qui nous annonçons
le message de Dieu.
Le rappel
du jugement à venir
fait partie
de l'amour
que nous portons
à ceux
à qui nous annonçons
le message de Dieu.
Vous voyez ce parallèle
entre Ézéchiel
et le Christ
où ces deux passages
se rejoignent.
Dieu rappelle
par Ézéchiel
à un moment
les morts
qui seront au milieu
des idoles,
la peste,
la famine,
toutes ces épées.
Voyons le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
qui rappelle
ces jours
où les ennemis
vont les environnements
de tranchées,
vont les détruire
eux et leurs enfants.
L'annonce
de l'évangile,
donc,
pour résumer
là sur ce point
où nous sommes
en train
de se verser 11,
nous devons
pas juste
être en train
d'être indignés,
mais nous devons
prier.
Prier pour le salut
de ceux
à qui nous annonçons
l'évangile.
La prière
nous amène
à nous aligner
sur le cœur
de Dieu
et à éprouver
la compassion
que Dieu éprouve
pour ses perdus.
La compassion
va nous amener
aussi à pouvoir
manifester
cet appel
à la repentance
et ce rappel
du jugement
à venir.
Et là,
c'est encore
un grand rappel
de la manifestation
de cet esprit
de force,
d'amour
et de sagesse
qui doit
nous habiter.
Si nous voulons
étouffer
l'esprit,
alors,
à un moment,
nous allons couper
l'appel
à la repentance,
nous allons couper
le rappel
du jugement
à venir
parce que nous avons
peur de choquer
les gens.
Mais l'évangile,
c'est que l'évangile
coûte
et nous devons
être prêts
à cause de cette vérité
à accepter
de perdre
notre réputation,
à accepter
même peut-être
que des relations
soient brisées.
Je ne parle pas
d'être en train
de se disputer
parce que tu as annoncé
l'évangile,
mais parce que tu as
annoncé l'évangile,
tu as fait cet appel
à la repentance,
tu as rappelé
le jugement à venir
et le besoin
d'être réconcilié
avec Dieu.
Si cette personne
décide de ne plus
te parler
et que tu l'aimais
beaucoup,
rends grâce à Dieu
pour ça.
Mais tu auras
fait ton devoir.
C'était
notre premier point
là-dessus.
Le deuxième point
de cette vérité centrale,
donc le premier point
c'était de pouvoir
être en train
d'annoncer cette vérité
avec le prix
que ça coûte
et d'être indigné
de pouvoir ressentir
la compassion de Dieu.
Le deuxième point
est lié
à cet aspect
du jugement.
Et donc là,
c'est Ézéchiel
qui devait enseigner
à ses auditeurs,
il devait les enseigner
sur la compréhension
des différentes manifestations
de ce jugement.
C'est ce que nous lisons
au verset 12.
Verset 12,
Celui qui sera loin
mourra de la peste.
En fait,
même pas verset 12,
c'est verset 12 à 14.
Donc,
je vais le relire.
Celui qui sera loin
mourra de la peste.
Celui qui sera prêt
tombera par l'épée.
Celui qui restera
et sera assiégé
périra par la famine.
J'assouvirai ainsi
ma fureur sur eux.
Et vous saurez
que je suis l'éternel
quand leurs morts
seront au milieu
de leurs idoles,
autour de leurs hôtels,
sur toute colline élevée,
sur tous les sommets
des montagnes,
sous tout arbre vert,
sous tout chêne,
tout fût,
là où ils offraient
des parfums
d'une agréable odeur
à toutes leurs idoles.
J'étendrai ma main
contre eux
et je rendrai le pays
plus solitaire
et plus désolé
que le désert de Dibla,
partout où ils habitent.
Et ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel.
Donc,
sur ce deuxième point
de cette vérité centrale
énoncée,
concentrons-nous déjà
sur le verset 12.
Dieu allait manifester
sa fureur
et quelle que soit
la manifestation
du jugement,
tous allaient être touchés.
C'est-à-dire,
ce que Dieu est en train
de dire,
que ce soit l'épée,
la peste,
la famine,
l'exil,
vous tous
qui allez subir
ce jugement,
il n'y a pas quelqu'un
qui va dire à un moment
j'ai été épargné.
Même ceux qui auraient
été épargnés par l'épée,
la peste,
la famine,
l'exil serait un jugement.
L'exil serait une manifestation
de ce jugement.
Certains pouvaient donc
être rassurés,
mais Dieu est en train
de dire que même là,
partout où ils iraient,
la sentence de Dieu
allait les poursuivre.
Aujourd'hui,
encore,
beaucoup de personnes
vont placer
leur curseur
de comparaison.
Quand ils vont
essayer d'évaluer,
de s'évaluer,
ils vont placer
leur curseur
de comparaison
non selon
les standards de Dieu,
mais ils vont placer
leur curseur
de comparaison
avec ce qui peut
leur arriver
et ce qui peut
arriver aux autres.
Donc,
il y a des moments
où on va trouver juste.
Il y a certaines personnes
qui vont subir
certains événements,
certaines situations
et nous allons juger
que c'est mérité
parce qu'ils ont mal fait.
Et lorsqu'il y a,
par exemple,
d'autres personnes
qu'on va juger innocentes
qui vont subir
certaines choses,
on va trouver
qu'ils ne méritaient pas
de pouvoir les subir.
mais quand nous réfléchissons
ainsi,
c'est toute notre grille
de lecture
qui est faussée.
Ce que nous devons
comprendre,
c'est que
toute l'humanité
est touchée
par le péché
et par ses conséquences.
Là,
Dieu est en train
de dire,
il est en train
de faire comprendre
à Israël
parce que certains
pouvaient se dire
à un moment,
je ne me sens pas
concerné,
mais non,
tous allaient vivre
une manifestation
du jugement.
Il n'y a pas un
qui allait dire,
j'ai échappé.
Et pourquoi ?
C'est que dans le reste
que Dieu était en train
de se réserver,
ce reste devait passer
déjà par la repentance.
Quand on va considérer
un moment
qu'on ne mérite pas
un jugement ou autre,
on va trouver difficile
de pouvoir se repentir
ou on va trouver difficile
ce qui peut nous arriver.
Mais la Bible nous dit
à un moment,
pourquoi l'homme vivant
se plaindrait-il
qu'il se plaigne
de ses propres péchés ?
À un moment,
nous devons comprendre
un moment que
nos standards de jugement
ne doivent pas être faits
par rapport aux situations
d'autres personnes
et autres
ou de ce que nous voyons
dans d'autres continents
et autres.
Nos standards doivent être
par rapport à la justice
de Dieu.
Et si nous nous comparons
par rapport à la justice
de Dieu,
aucun de nous
n'est sauvé,
même ceux
qui vont se considérer
comme innocents.
Parce que
nous sommes déjà
nés dans le péché.
Déjà, rien que le fait
d'être nés dans le péché,
aucun de nous
ne peut considérer
un moment
qui ne mérite pas
ce qu'il peut vivre.
La Bible,
et donc comme je dis,
à un moment,
si nous sommes en train
de partir dans cet aspect,
nous sommes en train
d'aller dans une grille
de lecture qui est faussée.
Mais la Bible nous rappelle
à un moment
que tout homme
qui est séparé de Dieu
ne peut pas connaître
sa paix.
Israël avait abandonné
la loi de l'éternel,
le jugement allait
les poursuivre,
où qu'ils soient.
Tout homme
séparé de Dieu
et qui est encore
dans le péché,
qui n'a pas connu
la réconciliation
avec Christ,
ne peut pas connaître
la paix.
Quel que soit
ce qu'il peut dire,
à un moment,
il peut dire,
moi je suis à l'abri,
je vis bien,
j'ai tout ça,
je suis...
Non.
Quand chacun de nous
fait l'examen
de son cœur,
chacun va savoir
qui n'a pas de paix.
On essaye de trouver
la paix au travers
de beaucoup de choses,
on va essayer de trouver
la paix par le divertissement,
par plein d'autres choses,
par la poursuite
dans d'autres religions,
dans beaucoup de choses,
mais on ne peut pas
trouver cette paix
parce qu'il n'y a que
Dieu qui donne cette paix.
Et souvent,
ces hommes,
et quand ces hommes
se permettent même
de dire,
j'ai cette paix de Dieu,
c'est à ce moment
que le jugement de Dieu
les surprend.
C'est à ce moment
que le jugement de Dieu
surprend,
et on ne peut pas
échapper au jugement
de Dieu.
Prenons conscience
que rien ici-bas
ne pourrait être
une source de refuge
pour n'importe
lequel d'entre nous.
Quand le jour
du jugement de Dieu
se manifeste,
par contre,
nous,
en tant que chrétiens,
nous ne pouvons pas
être surpris.
Nous savons à un moment
que le péché
appelle
le jugement de Dieu.
Nous sommes conscients
de cela.
nous voyons
Daniel,
Ézéchiel,
Jérémie,
ils ont vécu
ces événements difficiles.
Quand Dieu est en train
de juger la nation,
ils ont vécu
ces choses difficiles.
Ils ont même été secoués
parce qu'on peut même
penser que Daniel
a été castré
puisque les eunuques
à la cour,
quand vous étiez eunuques
dans les cours orientales,
les cours royales,
vous étiez castrés.
ils ont vécu
des choses difficiles.
Mais Dieu témoigne
au travers
des écrits,
de ce qu'ils sont
en train de dire,
ils sont en train
de témoigner
que Dieu était
un refuge
pour tous ceux
qui allaient se repentir
et qui allaient comprendre
que la main de Dieu
était derrière.
Et voilà pourquoi
il va dire
« Et ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel ».
Ézéchiel
l'avait déjà compris.
Ézéchiel avait compris
que c'était l'éternel.
que c'était la main de Dieu
derrière ce jugement.
Voilà pourquoi j'ai dit
« Nous, en tant que chrétiens,
nous ne devons pas
être surpris
quand le jugement
de Dieu se manifeste
parce que Dieu
est vrai dans sa parole.
La Bible nous dit
à un moment
« Il n'y a point de paix
pour le méchant ».
Et souvent,
nous avons tendance
à considérer,
on va se dire,
mais l'exemple
qui me reste toujours,
c'était une fois
sur les réseaux sociaux,
Brad Pitt avait donné
5 millions de dollars.
Il y avait une tornade
quelque part
qui avait été détruite
et il y avait quelqu'un
qui disait à un moment
« Mais comment,
quand Brad Pitt
a fait un tel geste,
comment Dieu
peut lui refuser
le paradis ? »
Mais ça,
quand des chrétiens
témoignent ainsi,
ces chrétiens
ne comprennent pas.
Ce que la Bible
nous dit à un moment,
c'est que si nous ne sommes
pas réconciliés
avec Dieu,
nous ne connaîtrons
jamais la paix,
quel que soit
ce que nous pouvons
imaginer ou penser.
et donc,
Ézéchiel,
Daniel,
Jérémie
et bien d'autres
n'étaient pas surpris
par le jugement de Dieu.
Ils avaient compris
que la main de Dieu
était derrière.
Ils avaient compris
aussi que Dieu,
en permettant
que le jugement
tombe sur ce reste,
Dieu était en train
de se préserver
un reste
au travers
de la repentance.
Au verset 13,
il dit
Avec le châtiment
qui allait s'exercer,
Israël allait
comprendre enfin
que leur péché
était à l'origine.
Ils ne l'avaient pas
encore compris.
Et voilà pourquoi
Dieu demande à Ézéchiel
d'avoir de la compassion.
de l'exprimer,
même par des gestes.
Mais il faut que Ézéchiel
mette cette en face
pour qu'Israël
prenne conscience.
Frappe de la main,
frappe de la main.
Israël prenne conscience
que Dieu
était l'auteur,
était celui
qui est en train
de gouverner
ce jugement.
Et vous voyez,
c'est ce qui était
ce passage
que nous lisons.
Nous l'avons déjà
médité en lisant
les versets 5
ou verset 7.
Et donc,
Dieu est en train
de parler
l'endroit
de leur adoration.
Là où ils avaient
adoré ces dieux,
là où ils s'étaient
prosternés,
là où ils avaient
offert l'encens,
cet endroit
d'adoration
serait aussi
le lieu de mort
de plusieurs.
Là où ils avaient
offert de l'encens
pour manifester
de la vie,
de la joie,
c'est une odeur
de mort
qui allait désormais
flotter.
Et pour Israël,
la conscience
que Dieu est en train
de mettre
en emphase,
le salaire
du péché
était la mort.
Et pour nous aussi,
dans cette prise
de conscience,
quelle que soit
la façon
dont le péché
peut se présenter
à nous,
quelles que soient
les excuses
que tu veux donner
à un péché,
le salaire du péché,
c'est la mort.
Mais nous voyons là
comment Dieu
est en train
d'user de patience
envers Israël,
même envers ceux
en qui il est en train
de frapper de famine,
de peste,
de l'épée.
Dieu est en train
de les appeler
à se repentir.
Dieu aurait pu
raser Israël.
D'ailleurs,
même dans ce terme
de l'alliance,
c'était ça.
Mais Dieu aussi
avait prévu un moment
dans sa patience,
dans son amour,
il avait promis aussi
qui les restaurerait.
Lorsqu'il nous arrive
de vivre
les conséquences
du péché
dans notre vie,
c'est pour que nous
réalisions
combien nous sommes
éloignés
des standards de Dieu.
Chaque fois
que nous pouvons
vivre cela,
nous réalisons,
quand nous prenons
conscience un moment
que mon péché
a des conséquences
et qu'un moment,
par rapport à certaines choses
que j'ai faites,
par rapport à mon péché,
je peux vivre
les conséquences
du péché,
je suis en train
de prendre conscience
aussi de combien
est proche
la main de miséricorde
de Dieu.
Déjà,
sur le principe,
le salaire du péché
sous la mort,
ça veut dire que
dès le moment
où tu pèches,
tu devrais mourir.
Mais si tu n'es pas
encore mort
malgré tes multiples péchés,
c'est parce que
la grâce de Dieu
est en train d'agir
pour t'appeler
à la repentance,
la grâce de Dieu,
la patience de Dieu
est en train
de s'exercer
pour que tu réalises
combien,
malgré tous tes efforts,
tu es éloigné
des standards de Dieu
et combien tu as besoin
de reconnaître
que Dieu est vrai
par sa justice,
par ses jugements.
C'est ce qu'il était
en train de leur dire
à partir de ce verset 13,
de prendre conscience
à un moment
que leur péché
allait produire
des conséquences,
allait les amener
dans une déception.
Mais cette prise de conscience,
cette prise de conscience,
c'était de prendre conscience
que le péché
a des conséquences.
Et il continue
au verset 14,
il va dire
« J'étendrai ma main
contre eux
et je rendrai le pays
plus solitaire
et plus désolé
que le désert de Dibla,
partout où ils habitent
et ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel. »
Dieu est en train
de parler de ce pays
donc je vous rappelle
l'introduction
que j'ai faite.
Dieu amène Abraham.
Abraham peut
déjà constater
combien ce pays
est magnifique
et Dieu lui promet
un moment
« J'amènerai
tes descendants
ici sur cette terre. »
Et il y a même
cette expression
qui est devenue
populaire pour nous
à un moment
qu'on va parler
« Le pays où coule
le lait et le miel. »
C'est une expression
qui vient de la Bible
et c'est comme ça
que Dieu désignait
la terre de Canaan
pour dire un moment
qu'ils allaient trouver
tout ce dont ils avaient besoin.
Mais Dieu dit maintenant
que ce pays
où coulait
le lait et le miel
allait être vidé
de ses habitants.
Il allait être livré
à la solitude
et à la désolation.
Et aujourd'hui encore
je pense
pour ceux
ici déjà
quelques heures
d'entre vous
ont pu voyager
en Israël
c'est une des terres
une des terres
où il est très difficile
de pouvoir planter
quelque chose.
C'est même un miracle
quand vous arrivez
à faire pousser
des choses
sur cette partie
des déserts.
Mais pourtant
on voit la grâce
de Dieu là-dessus
et donc Dieu
à un moment
parle d'un jugement
qui va arriver
il parle de tendre
sa main
sur ce pays
de le rendre
plus solitaire
et plus désolé
à cause des conséquences
de leur péché.
Dieu allait
étendre sa main
contre les idolâtres
et leurs hôtels
et les lieux
d'hôtels
allaient tomber
dans l'oubli.
C'est
une parfaite
illustration
parce que
la prise de conscience
quand Dieu
est en train
de parler
à Ézéchiel
c'est que
il ne prenait
pas conscience
c'était très important
il pouvait prendre conscience
à un moment
il pouvait se dire
ce sont les dieux
de Babylone
qui ont été plus forts
et qui nous ont
enfin là
voilà
les dieux de Babylone
ont été forts
le jugement est arrivé
et c'est
les dieux des Babyloniens
qui étaient plus forts
que notre Dieu
et qui nous ont conduit
là-bas.
Mais Dieu est en train
de préciser
et il veut vraiment
illustrer ça
ces choses
ne vous arrivent pas
par accident.
Ça avait été établi
plusieurs siècles avant
quand j'ai établi
mon alliance
avec vous
je vous avais dit
si vous obéissez
à la loi
voici ce que vous aurez
mais si vous désobéissez
voilà ce que vous aurez
et là
Dieu établit
et accomplit
intégralement
tout ce qu'il avait
dit
plusieurs siècles avant
et tous ces passages
là
en faisaient partie
tous ces passages
que nous avons lu
des versets 11
au verset 14
en faisaient partie
et donc
Dieu est en train
de souligner
qu'à cause de l'idolâtrie
qui s'était développée
dans le pays d'Israël
Dieu allait vider
le pays
de ses habitants
Dieu était même
déjà en train
de le faire
et ils devaient donc
prendre conscience
qu'ils étaient à Babylone
non pas à cause
du hasard
d'une malchance
mais ils étaient là
parce que
ils avaient désobéi
à la loi de Dieu
beaucoup de personnes
veulent rejeter
le principe
du jugement
de Dieu
et veulent y voir
à un moment
un aspect du hasard
ou autre
le hasard n'existe pas
Dieu gouverne
toutes choses
selon sa volonté
selon ses desseins
à un moment
Dieu peut permettre
lorsque sa patience
peut être arrivée
à son terme
Dieu permet
que nous vivions
les conséquences
de notre péché
d'ailleurs
même nous-mêmes
pour ceux qui ont
des enfants
si à un moment
votre enfant désobéit
désobéit
plusieurs fois
de façon répétée
par rapport à quelque chose
vous allez devoir
le corriger
c'est la même chose
c'est cet enseignement
que Dieu nous donne
il était obligé
de corriger Israël
mais bien sûr
dans cette correction
il allait falloir
détruire
l'objet
de leur idolâtrie
c'était ses hôtels
il allait rendre
le pays
désolé
donc le désert
de Dibla
c'était une zone
très désertique
où vous trouviez
beaucoup de serpents
vous trouviez
des serpents
c'était une zone
très désertique
et donc il prend
cette illustration
pour manifester aussi
ce que produisent
les conséquences
du péché
c'est-à-dire
Ézéchiel est en train
de pointer
il ne s'agit pas juste
Ézéchiel doit prendre
compassion
Ézéchiel doit annoncer
les iniquités
d'Israël
mais il faut aussi
qu'Israël prenne
conscience
de ce que
le péché produit
des conséquences
que le péché produit
et ses conséquences
étaient assez graves
et souvent
nous ne prenons pas
toujours conscience
même
au sein
de nos nations
nous ne prenons pas
conscience
de ces manifestations
du péché
qui peuvent même
être un peu
en parallèle
avec ce que Dieu
est en train de dire
de rendre le pays
plus solitaire
plus désolé
regardant
les faux dieux
que nous pouvons
nous créer
même au sein
de nos nations
ces faux dieux
ne peuvent pas
nous protéger
de ce que produisent
les conséquences
du péché
que de ce que
produisent
la tristesse
la désolation
la solitude
la perte de repères
on est
dans un temps
de patience
de Dieu
mais nous voyons
une manifestation
aussi des jugements
de Dieu
contre l'idolâtrie
là c'était
à l'époque
d'Israël
mais nous pouvons
aussi le voir
dans notre cas
et voilà pourquoi
au travers de ces choses
dans cette conclusion
pour aujourd'hui
nous devons voir
l'amour de Dieu
qui est témoigné
Dieu est en train
de témoigner
son amour
envers Israël
en demandant
à Ézéchiel
de pouvoir
rendre encore
plus expressif
l'appel à la repentance
Dieu demande
à Ézéchiel
d'être encore
plus expressif
dans l'appel
à la repentance
c'était pour
Ézéchiel lui-même
parce que ça lui
permettait aussi
de mettre du sérieux
dans le message
qu'il était en train
de donner
de prendre conscience
d'avoir compassion
davantage compassion
davantage une prise
de conscience
par rapport à cela
mais pour les auditeurs
lorsque Ézéchiel
est en train
de taper du pied
de frapper des mains
c'était encore
pour marquer
dans la conscience
des auditeurs
l'appel à la repentance
Ézéchiel
devait encore
plus fortement
exprimer
la réalité
du jugement
à venir
et il devait
exprimer
la réalité
du jugement
à venir
parce que
toutes ces choses
horribles
vous voyez
c'est ce qu'il dit
sur toutes
les méchantes
abominations
toutes ces choses
horribles
étaient en train
d'arriver
parce qu'ils avaient
péché
et le péché
allait apparaître
encore plus clairement
lorsque l'exécution
des châtiments
allait avoir lieu
c'est ce que signifie
le verset 13
lorsque
la manifestation
du jugement
allait arriver
quel que soit
l'endroit
où ils avaient pu
adorer ces idoles
ces endroits
allaient être frappés
par le jugement
et donc
que Israël
subisse
l'oeuvre
de l'épée
de Dieu
que Israël
subisse la peste
parce que certains
sont morts
par la peste
par la famine
le cannibalisme
l'exil
dans d'autres nations
quel allait être
le point
ils sauront
que je suis
l'éternel
tous
allez reconnaître
que c'est
l'éternel
qui agit
et pour finir
lisons
ces
en parallèle
c'est la même chose
nous voyons
le Dieu
qui est
ce message unique
il n'y a pas de
Ézéchiel
n'a pas un message
différent de celui
de Jérémie
Jérémie n'a pas
un message différent
de celui d'Ésaïe
nous avons même lu
le passage
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
l'évangile
est constant
et
comment rappeler
même
quand on parlait
de la réforme
beaucoup de personnes
quand on parle
de la réforme
protestante
le terme
réforme
ne va pas être
pris avec
quelque chose
de nouveau
qui est rajouté
non
les réformateurs
rappelaient
la vérité
biblique
Lamentation 3
verset 31
à 42
voilà ce que dit
Jérémie
et qui pourrait
résumer
ce sur quoi
nous avons médité
dans les versets
11 à 14
ce matin
la mort
verset 1
Ce passage
peut résumer
ce que Dieu
est en train
de demander
à Ézéchiel
dans ce sens
Dieu appelle
Ézéchiel
à manifester
de la compassion
parce que
Dieu
dans ses jugements
il ne le fait pas
parce qu'il est
en train
il n'est pas
un Dieu
masochiste
il le fait
parce qu'il est
en train
de corriger
Israël
ce n'est pas
volontiers
qu'il était
en train
de les humilier
mais c'est
parce qu'il y avait
eu des manifestations
du péché
le péché
à cause
de la justice
de la sainteté
de Dieu
le péché
appelait
à des conséquences
et à cause
de ces conséquences
Dieu
prononçait
son jugement
et quand il prononçait
il était en train
de préciser
si Israël
pensait
que c'était
le fruit
du hasard
il fallait
qu'Israël
prenne conscience
que c'est Dieu
qui l'avait
ordonné
si certains
trouvaient
cette situation
injuste
il fallait
qu'ils se souviennent
de leur propre péché
et donc du fait
que la grâce
de Dieu
est nécessaire
et cet appel
à la repentance
recherchant nos voies
et son don
les versets
40 à 42
c'est tout ce que
Dieu rappelle aussi
au travers
des équels
à un moment
ils sauront
que je suis l'éternel
et nous avions déjà
abordé ça
sur une partie
du chapitre 6
où nous voyons
même chapitre 5
nous voyons que
malgré la puissance
et la profondeur
de ce jugement
c'est l'amour
de Dieu
qui est en train
d'être manifesté
c'est paradoxal
mais c'est l'amour
de Dieu
qui est en train
d'être manifesté
pour que Israël
puisse être restauré
dans l'alliance
avec Dieu
et même
au-delà
pour qu'une nouvelle
alliance
encore plus excellente
que celle
à laquelle
ils avaient échoué
puisse être établie
avec Dieu
gloire à Dieu
Amen